Well.
So who are the chronic for and why is it
important for a post 2015 a agreement on
sustainable development to think about
the chronic coupon there are getting
onto a half a billion people who are
poor over many years or for a lifetime
or possibly pass that property on to
their children.
And they're trapped in poverty,
partly because of politics,
partly because of the institutions of
the market,
which don't operate in their favor.
And this isn't just because of a dearth
of opportunities or a lack of economic
growth,
although that is obviously very
important.
So what does it take to,
um,
get people permanently out of poverty
and address chronic poverty?
Uh,
and what can an international framework
do to help this on its way?
It takes good politics,
progressive policies to improve the
situations of these longterm poor
people.
Measures like social assistance,
seeing children through school for many
years,
age of pro poorest growth,
uh,
initiatives and a political society
that's,
uh,
begins to recognize the needs and
interests of chronic keep white people.
That doesn't happen very often because
chronically bought people don't organize
themselves very well.
And so they need allies.
The international community can be an
ally for the chronically poor.
They can set,
uh,
poverty eradication goal and targets,
which really address chronic poverty.
They can desegregate progress so that we
look at the progress made by the bottom
5% 10% 20% of the population.
They can,
of course,
set specific goals,
education,
seeing children through nine or 10 years
of,
of education,
quality education to help them get out
of poverty so they can be a major ally.
International community can be a major
ally for the chronic important.